It's Never As Good As it seemed it's
never as bad as it seems what my
granddad always used to say I've never
really told anyone but my granddad
actually passed away the day before my
final interview at WISE it was expected
so it doesn't make it any easier but it
was expected and then obviously it was a
bit like right okay what do I do here do
I cancel this yeah going back to that
sheer want that need to make it work he
wouldn't wanted me to pass up the
opportunity me not going he's not going
to bring it back so maybe in this case
not as bad as it seemed Optima Car went
to London got the job and here we are
nearly seven years later but again never
get too high Never As Good As It Seems
and the past six months where it's been
a little bit tougher I've had to work
much harder never as bad as it seems